Congratulations Class of 2018 we should
be so proud of ourselves for all our
accomplishments and hard work and bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla
this week we have been hearing that
non-stop friends and family take
pictures of us as if we were the John
Harvard statue itself hug us to make up
for our lack of physical contact over
the past four years and continually
commend us on the most wonderful
achievement of our lives thus far
Harvard but let's be honest with
ourselves it's been far from a smooth
journey let's not forget that you
contracted mono within the first week of
arriving to campus you sold your soul to
David Malin for an I took CS50 t-shirt
you never dated anyone seriously or at
all and your grandma is panicking how
could you do this to her you
concentrated in English or in economics
but you still can't explain inflation
you got a 32% on your or go mid term and
worse a b-plus in the Hebrew Bible you
slacker you drank more wine than water
and wished more than once that someone
had stopped you from finishing those
scallion pancakes at the Kong over four
years you made a total of three phone
calls home and you stopped practicing
the piano you were so good and now
you're still in the job search process
these things take time mom and dad so to
all that I say congratulations
we did make it through a significant
amount though we trekked through a
hundred and ten inches of snow freshman
year broke thousands of plastic forks
eating red spice chicken during the HUD
strike and came to realize those wisdom
tooth surgeries were actually the mumps
we learned a whole new language in which
blocking meant make making your first
harvard enemies long distance meant an
eight minute shuttle ride and advising
meant receiving an email once a semester
we learned to question our surroundings
I've heard some interesting ones over
the past few years such as is anyone in
the Lampoon funny how does Crimson key
measure facial symmetry does Harvard
model Congress actually attend any
conferences during their fully funded
vacations why would women want to join
the Hasty Pudding or anyone for that
matter
why do Harvard acapella groups purposely
arrange their music to sound off-key and
what does she mean when she says she
took on her position as punch master of
the bee to truly make a difference
these are all valid questions and for
answers please email Dean Khurana at FAS.
harvard.edu with USGSO sanctions in
the subject line for a guaranteed quick
response but how much of this really
matters from the moments we walked for
the yard as wide-eyed freshmen as former
valedictorians debate champions and
team captains
we have questioned our choices and
performances we enrolled in a course
without realizing called rejection 10a
which although tough was still more
tolerable than expose 20 in my first two
years of college I went through eight
comp processes and got into only two of
those organizations I was rejected from
classes anyone wanting to write a
25-page paper on carbon taxes should be
allowed to do so and worse I was quaded
and with each apparent failure or
letdown I questioned myself was I not
smart enough not talented enough not
Upper East Side enough but the number of
times we applied to expose 40 or the
number of times we comp the advocate and
still didn't get in or the number of
times we sat on a bench during a
basketball game is not what defines us
what matters is what we did next
we found the strength to try again to
discover another creative outlook and to
wake up the next morning and train even
harder what matters is that we learn
from our mistakes to never again speak
to a crimson reporter and to only go to
UHS if you wanted an IV after yardfest
so tomorrow when we exit these gates we
will take with us not only our GPAs or
hoops prizes or capacity to write a
20-page paper in one night but also our
grit and determination our ability to
face the inevitable challenges ahead we
will of course also take with us our
understanding of very useful theoretical
models and hype
medical thought experiments a perception
that 7 minutes late is still on time and
a dependence on Lesley Kerwin to tell us
when to wear our snow boots we have much
to be grateful for Thank You Harvard for
giving us friends to wake us up for our
9 a.m. finals for giving us grad
students to lead us through four hours
of silence in section and for somehow
making our SLS's count as SPU's so
family and friends to couch our cameras
open your arms for that hug and join me
in celebrating the class of 2018
let's celebrate all the battles we have
lost and all the messes we have made
class of 2018 keep venturing keep
falling down and keep getting right back
up thank you